the 71st annual Academy Awards brought
to you by Pepsi the joy of Cola revlon
revolutionary products for revolutionary
women
chevrolet who invites you to see the USA
in your Chevrolet and AT&T personal
Network Communications has finally
caught up with the way you live
ladies and gentlemen two-time Academy
Award winner Steven Spielberg
he wanted to take us places we could
never have imagined and so he imagined
them for us
he is Stanley Kubrick
he died before he can witness the
century he had already made famous with
2001 a Space Odyssey Stanley wanted us
to see his movies absolutely as he
envisioned them he never gave an inch on
that he dared us to have the courage of
his convictions and when we take that
dare were transported directly to his
world and were inside his vision and in
the whole history of movies there's been
nothing like that vision ever it was a
vision of hope and wonder of Grace and a
mystery it was a gift to us and now it's
a legacy we will be challenged and
nourished by that for as long as we keep
the courage to take his dare and I hope
that will be long after we've said our
thanks and our goodbyes